je suis venu vous raconter une histoire
l'histoire d'un sourire le sourire d'un
héros universel la petite égyptienne
je suis sur cette photographie vous la
connaissez la photographie de sabine
weiss
cette photographie sabine weiss l'a
réalisé en novembre 1983 j'avais une
dizaine d'années je n'en dirai pas plus
et là j'ai une question pour vous je
suis un peu curieux qui parmi vous avais
déjà vu cette photographie l'une des
plus connues du xxème siècle fait la
même j'espère et soyez sincères j'en
étais sûr beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
monde et je vais vous faire un aveu il
ya quelques années dans mon petit coin
de corrèze natale moi aussi dans ma
petite chambre j'avais pas un poster une
carte postale de la petite égyptienne
ce sourire universelle c'est une des
photographies des plus connus au monde
une des icônes et le mot est fort du 20e
siècle
je suis photographe mais je suis
historien de formation et depuis une
vingtaine d'années je suis tantôt l'un
tantôt l'autre ceux qui me connaissent
disent que je suis historien au milieu
photographes sur les bords et parfois l'
inverse
je suis un photographe qui aiment les
projets au long cours un an deux ans
trois ans 5 ans 10 ans des projets qui
raconte des histoires humaines
j'essaye de poser des mots posés des
visages les mémoires qui n'en n'ont pas
l'appli tjp sienne c'est le cas
la photographie pour moi c'est la preuve
c'est la preuve est l'expérience la
mienne celle des autres c'est le temps
c'est un voyage
c'est tout ça à la fois
et puis parfois je me dis dans les
moments de grande solitude
à quoi ça sert tout ça ça va intéresser
qui c'est pour ça que je suis content de
vous rencontrer aujourd'hui puisque au
moins pendant quelques minutes je me dis
voilà je vais au moins avoir ce moment
partagé avec vous pour vous raconter à
un moment de ma vie
il y a quelques mois de l'autre côté de
la méditerranée en egypte mais avant
d'aller en egypte arrêtons-nous d'abord
à paris
tout à l'heure je vous ai parlé de
sabine weiss petit clin d'oeil à sabine
elle à 91 ans presque aujourd'hui franco
suisse et si vous voulez faire un petit
peu de l'histoire de la photographie je
vous dirais juste que c'est une des
contemporaine une des amis de robert
doisneau
je suis sûr que vous connaissez robert
doisneau willy ronis je lui dois tout en
photographie c'est lui qui m'a lancé ya
une vingtaine d'années petit clin d'oeil
à willy qui n'est plus de ce monde
elle a grandi elle a photographié avec
ces deux monstres sacrés de la
photographie française
vous avez vu la photographie tout à
l'heure regardez celle ci n est pas tout
à fait identiques
je suis historien de formation ça a été
dit tout à l'heure j'aime les documents
d'avant et j'aime les visages
d'aujourd'hui ma première surprise quand
il a fallu aller plus loin dans cette
histoire c'était d'abord retrouver le
matériau historique ce que j'ai oublié
de vous dire et et c'est aussi pour ça
que je fais ce métier deuxième aveu
c'est qu'il ya quelques mois tout est
parti de brazzaville capitale du congo
je rentre d'un voyage dans ce pays de
l'afrique centrale à côté de moi une
journaliste valérie je la connais à
peine elle le fait elle aussi un aveu
dans l'avion et elle me dit c'est toi tu
es photographe il doit savoir moi depuis
tout petit il ya une photographie qui me
fait rêver qui me qui m'émeut sans arrêt
un peu plus cette petite fille jeu
me brun de profil un paysage flou tu
dois savoir toit est en effet je me dis
que c'est sûrement la petite égyptienne
de sabine weiss valérie nivelon petit
clin d'oeil à valérie également le note
nous quittons à roissy quelques mois
après le téléphone sonne à mon métier
quand le téléphone sonne c'est bon signe
en général c'est plutôt des bonnes
nouvelles en général et on m'appelle
pour être l'un des neuf photographes
pour l'hommage national de son vivant
c'est rare pour sabine weiss pour les
huards disais que dans la vie il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas de hasard il ya que des
rendez vous j'aime cette idée là et
j'essaie de me nourrir au quotidien pour
ma photographie avec ce hasard qui n'en
est peut-être pas un je me permet
d'interpeller enfin sabine weiss sabine
weiss elle est là sur la photographie
c'est sa main tremblante elle à 91 ans
est en pleine forme je vous rassure mais
c'est toujours pareil quand je suis
arrivé chez elle avec valérie j'ai un
peu réveillé sa mémoire oubliée ans
comme disait le président léopold sédar
senghor la mémoire des hommes est
souvent oublieuse l'image est inversée
première première on va dire découverte
et je n'était qu'au début de beaucoup de
découvert cette histoire je suis
historien de formation
je voulais dit donc j'ai besoin de
quelque part de comme saint-thomas de
croire ce que je vois deuxième
révélation l'image que vous connaissez
toutes et tous elle avait été recadrée
en grossissant cela planches contacts
que j'ai fait ce jour-là pour mieux
comprendre pour rentrer dans l'histoire
tout simplement
il y à cette photo comme une petite
séquence de vie quelque part en novembre
1983 à louxor egypte
il y a la petite égyptienne qui est
toujours avec nous mais il ya à côté une
deuxième petite fille dans l'image
connue dans l'icône de la photographie
cette seconde petite fille qui s'appelle
zainab n'existe pas pour moi
me dis que dans mon for intérieur et
j'en fais la confession et valérie ça
surement peut-être via cette petite
fille noble juste à côté que peut-être
nous allons arriver à promettre à la
lumière à partir à la recherche de la
petite égyptienne
j'en parle à sabine weiss 91 ans je
voulais 10 qui souvent pour les
photographier dit humaniste faisait
beaucoup de photographies sont toujours
gardé la trace de ce qu'ils avaient pu
photographier noté en s'excusant presque
d'avoir fait à l'époque elle me dit tu
sais philippe moi je me rappelle juste
que cette petite fille qui faisait
partie d'un groupe de jeunes qui avaient
entre 10 et 12 ans près d'un temple aux
murs épais vendant des poupées des
poupées de chiffon
c'est tout en discutant un petit peu via
son assistant de l'or j'arrive à mettre
la main sur un petit carnet marqué
egypte novembre décembre 1983 et vous
voyez planches-contacts 51 il y en avait
100 sur l'egypte juste un petit mot mot
poser pour la postérité une jeune fille
cheveux noirs vous qui connaissez la
photographie vous voyez tout simplement
le lien entre les mots et des images à
partir de ce constat là et vous voyez
que nous avions très peu d'informations
un pays l'egypte une ville louxor une
icône un visage un sourire
la petite égyptienne nous partons en
egypte septembre 2014
louxor vous connaissez les grandes
lignes la situation politique sociale
économique de ce pays où tout est à
l'arrêt louxor c'était une des grandes
capitales du tourisme de masse le nil
les beautés du nil carnac
il n'y a plus rien jusqu'à nouvel ordre
tout s'est arrêté et première étape
retrouvez retrouver le territoire moi je
suis plutôt je connais bien l'afrique
noire je ne connaissais pas du tout
cette partie du monde nous avions un
contact dans nos bêtises on appelle ça
un fixeur c'est pas un très joli mot
mais une personne qui est censé en
savoir un peu plus quand nous sommes
arrivés à louxor et quand on lui a
montré la photographie j'avais plein
photocopies dans mes poches il n'avait
il était stupéfait on ne lui avait
jamais demandé ça c'est à dire trouver
une petite fille 31 ans après
en se demandant en demandant voilà aux
gens dans un contexte difficile où je
fais attention on ne sait pas qui est
qui qui fait quoi et donc une
déambulation de chorégraphie urbaine
s'est mis en place
louxor si vous connaissez ou si vous
avez déjà vu des images il ya deux rives
sabine se rappeler c'est elle arrive au
west donc il faut traverser le nil 31
ans après j'avais vraiment l'impression
dans un sentiment étrange d'intimité
presque dérangeante un peu parfois de
m'inscrire dans les pas de sabine weiss
nous traversons le nil majestueux 400
bateaux à l'arrêt par une touriste deux
ou trois petites navettes avec des
silhouettes d'abord et nous arrivons de
l'autre côté de l'autre côté c'est rive
ouest dans les notes de sabine nous
avions identifié trois villages comme
trois destinations possibles sans savoir
plus donc voyez vont porter vraiment
avec pas grand chose j'ai un peu
l'habitude dans ce métier mais là quand
même
c'était quand même un peu fort nous
arrivons est là avec à la fois force et
discrétion nous commençons à faire
voyager et la photographie c'est aussi
d'abord et avant tout un voyage l'école
la petite égyptienne
personne n'avait jamais vu cette
photographie malgré le monde dans lequel
connectés dans lequel nous vivons
personne n'avait jamais vu cette
photographie nous arrivons de l'autre
côté un groupe de taxi hélas assez
imposant à ces majestueux cuisance le
soleil fait 40 45 degrés il n'ya plus
toristes je voulais dit hélas la
photographie commencent à circuler
et puis je me souviens que un moment
donné il ya un homme mais vraiment
imposant j'avais vraiment envie d'être
d'accord plutôt avec lui qui me dit dans
un arabe que je ne comprends pas
elle ressemble à quelqu'un de la famille
de mehdi des à booth et il appelle un
garçon qui s'appelle esmael qui arrive
je me rappellerai toujours une douzaine
d'années tee shirt jaune fluo marquer
mais si ça devrait parler voilà est qui
et qui me qui regardent thomas incrédule
pensait bien et qu'ils regardent et le
monsieur imposant j'étais toujours
d'accord avec lui j'avais envie de
l'être encore plus dit nous dit ismael
s'est regardé ressemble à ta mère est à
ta soeur mais le pauvre on part avec lui
il nous emmène à 3 50 cents mètres de là
gardez en tête que tout ça s'est joué à
quelques centaines de mètres la famille
photographiée par sabine weiss en
novembre 83 vit toujours aujourd'hui
dans ce même quadrilatère de quelques
centaines de mètres à louxor mediavu
egypte nous arrivons près du temple de
médias à bout magnifique grandiose
j'avais l'impression de revisiter mes
cours de géographie de sixième on
apprend à l'égyptologie
un groupe de quatre cinq hommes qui
fument et qui buvaient tranquille on
arrive
j'arrive tout penaud et je leur montre
la photographie le monde rigole tout le
monde se marre sauf un qui dit rien
imposant et qui s'en va mon métier de
photographe me dit toujours que ce genre
d'événement d' accidents de la vie il
faut y aller je le suis il s'envole
centaines de mètres heroes vient je le
croise une photo le temps de médine est
à bout et derrière vous savez maintenant
où c'est que nous citions l'histoire
commence à dérouler s'accélère il
revient au café et là ils discutent dans
un long silence et d'écouté suivez moi
j'ai quelque chose à vous montrer on
rentre dans cette maison cette maison
c'est la sienne il y vit depuis presque
un demi-siècle rentrant dans la maison
il ya une photographie en haut à droite
il a elle été solide mur vous le voyez
elle est également d'asthme et avec
beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup de solennité
beaucoup de dignité
il nous dit tout simplement avec ses
mots à lui la petite égyptienne comme
vous l'appelez c'était ma femme elle
s'appelait oum kalthoum et non de la
grande chanteuse égyptienne
la petite égyptienne l'image iconique de
sabine weiss et oum kalsoum et là on se
dit c'est pas possible ça va trop vite
il est au courant il ya quelqu'un a reçu
un mail bons peuvent donc donc non que
non et là et là voilà vous voyez le
monsieur pleine dignité et l'histoire
s'accélère à nouveau moi j'avais les
planches-contacts les photocopies vous
voyez son regard je ne vous raconte pas
des histoires totalement incrédule et la
famille arrive à gauche c'est chabannes
le fils donc le fils qu'il a eu avec oum
kalsoum la petite égyptienne
vous allez à pas voir apparaître bientôt
amira 11 ans qui est donc la fille
cadette de oum kalsoum
il est il en est des poupées pour les
touristes à l'époque ils sont toujours
le même métier aujourd'hui la difficulté
c'est qu'il ya plus de touristes
l'histoire chance s'enchaînent et au
bout d'un moment
rappelez-vous début je vous avais dit
que sûrement l'histoire elle est passé
par la petite fille à côté qu'on avait
dans le visage avait été recadrée la
petite fille vous l'avez à droite c'est
la soeur d'oum kalsoum zainab est en
effet l'histoire qui est en train de
vous raconter l'histoire de ce sourire
de ce visage c'est d'abord une histoire
de femmes
si nous avons pu retrouver les visages
d'aujourd'hui par rapport à une
photographie de hyères c'était vraiment
grâce à zinal qui est à droite
émus très émus
elle nous montre une photographie de la
famille avec la maman à droite que vous
allez voir bientôt
et m me fait un ultime un ultime
l'ultime privilège rare pour les hommes
d'aller faire le pain le lendemain au
lever du jour avec elle et les femmes
dans une scène de vie incroyable où les
oiseaux qui s'envolent un moment c'est
un peu comme l'âme d'oum kalsoum qui
étaient partis aussi avec nos amis qui
étaient là bien présente et je ne sais
pas si vous vous rappelez la planche
contact au début il y avait un jeune
homme qui vous avez fait le salut comme
pour vous dire bonjour il s'appelait
tayeb tayeb vous l'avez aujourd'hui avec
son visage d'aujourd'hui il est là et
lui aussi était dans ce moment où toute
la famille
toute la famille reconstituée semilla en
face de nous dans un grand moment de des
changes tout simplement je vous l'avais
dit aujourd'hui son petit peu dans une
galère quelque part de ceux de vie de
survie mais avec beaucoup de dignité
et ils sont là encore aujourd'hui en
espérant de vivre de survivre
amira 11 ans je les photographier c'est
quasiment la fin du voyage et la fin de
mon histoire
aujourd'hui je les photographiais
quasiment au même âge que sabine weiss à
l'époque 11 ans et au bout de quelques
minutes on s'est rendu compte que les
deux histoires de ces héros ordinaires
d'une égypte en souffrance mais qu'ils
avaient beaucoup dit et continue à vivre
ce mélange est ce les murs de la maison
familiale l'image non recadrer de sabine
weiss
les photographies 2 la famille celle qui
du coup était surgit grâce à ma présence
hélas hélas hélas c'est la fin c'est
l'image c'est le portrait de amira qui
prend la suite la famille dont elle
souffre disait que um est une femme
libre
j'espère que amir à 11 ans connaîtra
cette liberté moi je suis photographe
pour sortir les gens de leur anonymat
pensez-y la prochaine fois vous ferez
des images de quelqu'un quand vous
photographiez quelqu'un vous le sortez
l'anima il existe il est là il a incarné
la liberté où m une femme libre amiral
sera peut-être et j'aimerais que nous
réfléchissions ensemble
qu'avons nous fait dans notre liberté
merci